hello and welcome to LED live if you're
new here please subscribe by clicking
that red button down below we're on the
road to 100k almost halfway there so
we'd really like your support and if
your reassurance on every Friday Tunes
in to join into the discussion we
appreciate you and thank you so much
I've been gone for a while and it's good
to be back welcome back it's good to
have a job so thank you guys hey listen
we're going to be discussing faith today
have you ever battled with or wrestled
with your own Christian faith what
happens when a very influential person
is battling with their faith find out on
this episode of LED live so things are
gonna be a little bit different in this
episode today we're gonna focus more on
apologetics and for those who don't know
apologetics is speaking in defense of
something usually having to deal with
religion or religious doctrines so I'm
gonna have you guys help me give a
response to someone like Marty Sampson
or anyone really who is struggling with
their own Christian faith yeah I mean
this is not somebody that's just like
way obscure right I mean it's a very
high profile person that is literally
like questioning his belief system right
now yeah a lot of influence a lot of
reach and has been doing this for a
really long time yeah but let's talk
about that phrase Christian faith what
does it mean to be a Christian follows
Christ yeah obviously you believe in
Christ
you know the Bible is a that's an
account of God's Word to us and that's
kind of how we understand the context of
what's going on in the world right now
I like how you kept it basic you know
just a follower of Christ that's that's
the foundation of it all all of these
things used to be the beliefs of Marty
Sampson but things have since changed
Marty Sampson is a songwriter for a
popular evangelical Christian band
called Hillsong UNITED and he's
announced that he's genuinely losing his
faith and this happened just a few weeks
after evangelical author Joshua Harris
announced that he no longer calls
himself a Christian have you guys heard
of Joshua Harris before yeah I actually
I think I've read a couple of his books
I kiss beating goodbye I've heard that
one that really changed culture a
Christian culture right you know I mean
he was coming at that from you know
having having good Christian values in
your dating system and is he saying he's
straight-up
atheist there is he just questioning and
doesn't know he's not a Christian
he's just rejected Christianity
altogether right you know what's
interesting to me about that was because
I try to think of put myself in that
position it's like knowing what I know
now and what I believe now I can't make
my mind not believe that you know what I
mean like how do you get to the place
that you're all because I'm like I'm
gonna just set this aside and it's like
not real you know like well that's what
we're gonna discuss in this episode so
let's let's try to understand where
these people are coming from yeah I
can't identify I was once agnostic
extremely I was raised in a Christian
home but Christians didn't have good
answers that's kind of my mission in
life is like I want to have answers for
the skeptics because this generation is
very skeptical and a lot of kids are
naughty they're just not even given
Christianity a chance and I feel like if
I would have got to if I was would have
been exposed to some of the people that
I know about now that have the you know
these apologetics it might have helped
me see the truth a lot earlier than I do
now this isn't something that happens
overnight
I mean Marty joined the band Hillsong
when he was 16 years old he's been in
ministry for more than half of his life
when Marty took to social media the
decline was quite rapid
he went from I'm struggling to I'm done
in a matter of weeks so here's the post
time for some real talk I'm genuinely
losing my faith and it doesn't bother me
like what bothers me now is nothing now
I read something like that and I see
someone who's just first of all has been
struggling for a really long time and
now they're kind of like breaking out of
the silence and saying yeah now I'm
ready now I'm really ready to talk and
hopefully maybe receive some counsels
and some answers because maybe it hasn't
been working the way I've been doing it
before but then when I read I'm genuine
genuinely losing my faith and it doesn't
bother me that sounds like someone who's
numb was just like completely done no no
yeah I would I would even venture to say
this is probably not something that just
happened in a few weeks
rice is something that was brewing under
the surface he probably said nothing and
you know in in the in the public eye
especially as a singer and a performer
you or probably taxed to the limit and
you know if you're not spending that
daily time connecting yourself with God
all of this can be just going through
the motions and you know this is just
sort of the iceberg
I'm sure exactly to be wrestling for
this long and reach a breaking point
that's right and then just be like it is
what it is and you don't feel bad about
it
yeah yeah yeah that's that's a little
alarming so have any of you ever
struggled in your own Christian walk I
don't know if you've gotten to this
point I don't think I've ever actually
struggled in the point where I came to a
place where I said there is no God even
when I went way out into the world I
think you know if you would have asked
me questions about God I would have
answered them just didn't have an
application for it in my life so I
actually don't know what that's like to
even be in a place that it's like I'm
questioning even the existence of I
don't know what that's like
yeah I would say the same there's never
in time in my life where I've gotten to
that point I have been there but like I
said it was Christians didn't have good
answers you know like it took me trying
everything else and finding out that all
of its just empty you know like like
Solomon said it's vanity vanity like I
did witchcraft and all this stuff and
it's just like all of it left me
hopeless and empty and then finally like
it when I was at rock bottom my cousins
like just showed up at the right time
and said dude this is what I've been
seen in the Bible it's real to me all
the answers are in here and it somebody
looked up to my parents had been trying
to show me this is true but to me you
know you're just my parents you're just
old or whatever but my cousin who I
looked up to showing it to me in a real
way like dude this is real I was like
all right let me try it and after
reading it for myself not just taking
the words from behind a pulpit like
digging in that's when God started to
reveal himself to me and that's when
Jesus says seek and you'll find knock
and I'll answer like you have to have
that type of desire I see atheists all
the time I've read the Bible
cover-to-cover it it doesn't mean
anything well because you're looking at
it trying to debunk it or something
you're not seeking with an open honest
heart and I think when God knows you're
truly seeking he'll reveal himself in a
way personal to you that nobody else can
deny and I
I wonder if this guy is seeking for that
type of experience or I think I can
understand it as well on the you know we
analyze Hollywood movies and we're able
to like all of a sudden pick something
out and people are always like what how
did you see that I did not see that
right when when you are opening your
eyes and you're looking for for a
particular something two people can have
a two totally different experiences
looking at the exact same thing and from
from our perspective even in a Hollywood
scene it's like we have this sort of big
picture understanding so we're able to
see how this like micro you know thing
that we're dealing with in life deals in
this big picture type of thing and so
some of these guys you know especially
agnostics that if they're reading the
Bible it's like they don't have this
grand view of it they're just literally
looking at the text in this like little
tiny way and to them it could just be
this as poetry you know it's before I
personally read Marty's post I was very
skeptical
in my experience back at home when
people would come to me saying oh
so-and-so you know has left the church
but they made it seem like the person
left God which was really not the case
there's a difference between leaving the
church like the building the fellowship
the congregation and leaving God so I
was saying man people are really blowing
this out of proportion he probably just
had a falling out in the band but he
hasn't really left God but later I came
to find out that he it seems like he's
on both sides not only has he left the
band but he's also having some serious
questions or had some serious questions
about God to the point where he's left
the faith completely so I just like to
go through his post and see where he's
coming from the questions that he he's
had and see if we can offer some answers
because unfortunately he didn't post
anything after that he just kind of left
it open-ended so maybe we can be of help
to someone out there who's searching
marty posted all of this on Instagram
and later deleted it but not before
someone could screen capture it so
that's good we have we have the post
this is a soapbox moment so here I go
how many preachers fall
many no one talks about it now that
particular point is interesting because
when preachers fall it's actually a
pretty big deal like it's all over the
place you're like oh I can't believe it
it's over the media and things so I
really wonder what like what angle he's
coming from when he says no one talks
about it right and and usually when the
Shepherd kind of like gets gets kicked
you know it scatters their sheep and
there's a big discussion around it as
well as maybe he's not talking about
into notable preachers you know maybe he
comes across people through the music
ministry of Hillsong or their travels or
whatever you want to call it and they
encounter people who have you know I've
been leading out in churches and they're
just like I'm I'm done I kind of wonder
if when preachers struggle who do they
talk to that's probably a bad situation
I mean I'm a pastor I'm struggling who
do I even go to I'm supposed to be
preaching to this congregation
especially if you're a lead pastor like
I can see this in the the
nondenominational scene if you set up
your own church and you're the lead dog
like who do you go to you know if you're
under that hierarchy you probably go to
the top guy if you're under some
denominational structure there's
somebody you know above you unless you
are the guy at the table you know you're
the the president or the Pope or
whatever you are like you know can you
imagine like the Pope needs count oh
yeah and how many preachers follow
Minnie okay good it shows that everyone
is redeemable I mean that's what's so
great about the Bible characters you
know it these aren't picture-perfect
stained-glass people that we could never
reach up to they've fallen and it just
kind of shows nobody's like perfect and
we're all redeemable I mean it's a good
thing that's a good point I mean you
also want to look at preachers and
pastors typically especially if they're
in the public eye like this people put
them on a pedestal wow this person is so
amazing they do all these amazing things
but we're all really in the same boat
you know struggling through this thing
called sin
and you know they're they're dealing
with it just like we're dealing with it
and I don't believe that we should hold
up on a pedestal anybody else because
when they do fall then everybody's like
paying attention to them and then they
you know go where they go so you know we
pastors need prayer just like everyone
else
how many miracles happen not many no one
talks about it okay pause there
hey we should talk about it because I
want just go bad calls happen this might
be a long led guys yeah I guess it
probably depends on what you define as
yeah people are gonna define miracles of
different ways if he's talking about the
kind of miracles we read about in the
Bible do we see a lot of those here in
the US yeah probably not I don't know
about other parts of the world so I
don't live there but other types of
miracles I mean there's all kinds of
things that happen people every day
probably call little miracles my
overnight freedom from addiction was a
supernatural miracle I mean that
probably the same thing right yeah well
a miracle is a shift in the natural
order of things yeah I mean in in the
case of drugs if you have a chemical
dependency I mean you're you're headed
down that road and if you know God takes
it away from you especially the
nightmare yeah every day that I tried to
say I'm not gonna do it in my own
strength irritable without we nauseous
without alcohol I prayed to God and saw
him I cannot do it in my own strength
I'm sarena to you you got to take it
from me I'm getting your permission woke
up the next day and none of those
effects I mean gone
and and then it became a constant
dependency on Christ it wasn't like it
was done like the tempter is always
there so now you're pumping gas and like
going beer steins in your face lord give
me the strength not to go in there and
get a beer and you and you're driving
home without a brown bag and you get to
experience victory every day but like
I'm saying the withdrawals and things
that's a supernatural event and then you
get to become dependent on Christ which
is a good thing I think why is the Bible
full of contradictions no one talks
about it so I took a class this summer
on
datings that was one of the thing that
came up is discrepancies if you will in
the bible and so it's it's almost always
little little things oftentimes it's
like numbers you know there's an example
I forget it's either and like first
Corinthians 10 or 11 Paul is talking
about a number of people that fell in
the wilderness the number that he
mentions in the New Testament is about a
thousand people different than what's
actually mentioned in the Old Testament
and so people look at that hey wait a
minute these numbers don't match like
what's going on here we do the same
thing all the time right we'll try to
recall something from memory it's not
like Paul was like toting around like
this girls all the time and that's
sitting referencing and these things are
huge and you're having to roll them out
you know what people have to understand
is the way that the Bible defines error
is deception right and so these little
things that we find in the Bible is not
purposefully trying to deceive people
nor does it change the intention of the
the story or the or the context that
were reading the main point it doesn't
detract from the main point so if Paul
says you know 22,000 people fell in the
wilderness and you go to numbers and it
says 23 well the point is people fell in
the wilderness because they sinned
against God and God pronounced a
judgement yeah so yeah I can see where
people see what seemed to be
contradictions in the Bible but the core
message like what what's being taught in
the Bible is is true it doesn't change
and
you know so I wish there was some
specific examples given okay there's not
he's big it's kind of easy to throw mud
and all of a sudden it's like you know
you're not really dealing with it but
you're kind of just casting that little
tiny seed of doubt to share and so you
can see his doubt actually coming
through and just the way he's even
mentioning this because if you really
had a discrepancy over that verse and
that problem you would bring that up and
be like hey how can we reconcile this
you know what I mean like that's not
gonna change my belief in God but to
kind of make a blanket statement like
there's contradictions in the Bible
therefore I lost my religion mm-hmm yeah
I've actually been in situations like
that and usually just to see what the
person is coming from I would ask the
question okay name one what's up ah
that's right that's you've encountered
and one of two things will happen they
said oh you know I don't know and then I
would know okay this person's just
regurgitating sneezes using it as an
excuse to not study the Bible or to just
toss their faith but if they do present
a contradiction I get excited because
I'm like okay let's let's hash this out
let's discuss it and realize there's
there's three main categories that
contradictions fall into and you named
one of them one is numbers the other one
is the message and the last one is
events and so I've actually I had some
examples of contradictions that I'd like
to share with you guys because here your
responses no pressure
yeah yeah but uh let's have some fun
sweet
so first got a category numbers in the
books of Mark and Luke it is stated that
two blind men were healed by Jesus
however in Matthew it says that one
blind man was healed in Jericho
contradiction so I would just first say
that Jesus actually probably healed lots
of people because when you went through
the villages I mean there was literally
not one sick person in those villages I
mean that's that's certain certain
experiences that the disciples had I
mean if you saw how many people live in
a village a thousand you know I mean if
you saw a ton of people like this all
the time being healed and you're trying
to remember this deeds
not to mention how many years later was
it actually written down I would have to
totally agree with Keith once again how
does that detract from the fact that
jesus healed if there's literally
examples of in healing thousands of
other people and yet there's like
there's like you know okay he did one or
he did to work
He healed the left eye not the right hi
to me that still doesn't take away from
from the absolute craziness that that's
really what Jesus spent his time doing
more than anything else he was healing
people the intention of the Bible writer
is not to deceive people so you
mentioned it was Mark and Luke yes okay
so mark and Luke we know were not
firsthand witnesses of the events in
Jesus is like so when they're writing
they're getting their information from
other people who were witnesses who were
witnesses so oftentimes eyewitness
accounts are not even considered
reliable in court because people's
memories have a tendency to fail not
everybody is a detail person either so
you know Matthew he's there he could
have remembered wrong there might have
been two he might have only seen one it
probably depends on working with
standing I mean there's all kinds of
variables but the point is the the
purpose of the passage is not to deceive
people on how many people were healed
the point is people were healed men
received their sight
you know and and how often does that
happen you know that was that was a big
deal back then like there's even a
question in the Bible or it's like you
know has it ever been heard that a man's
sight has been restored you know when it
when have you ever heard of that
happening and here it happens in front
of them
III think that if you had let's say
there was two guys and one was gonna go
and tell the King something and the
other one was gonna do something big and
prominent in it and and then the count
was different and so the outcome of
their their action would have been
different based on the story that would
totally change the context of would that
be an important number to remember if
there was really nothing that was gonna
happen after that I really don't see
that that that would raise question
marks and
yeah what I think happen is whoever
wrote one somebody saw Jesus heal
somebody I was like Jesus just heals
okay I write it down yeah somebody's
just healed tubular all right this guy
wrote to people I mean they're talking
to somebody else about all the other
guys get mean there's all kinds of
scenarios you know how people play
telephone you know this guy tells us
this guy and yeah it's nothing to say
okay toss the whole Bible out cuz one or
one guy got healed or two guys got
grants it's ludicrous
yeah and I'm gonna go back to what Mikey
said if you're looking for a reason to
doubt your enough yeah there's enough
information there for you to go well
this doesn't make any sense to me spoon
they're there for him to reject the
whole thing it's certainly not a
contradiction to Jesus's divinity and
claims to be the Son of God I mean after
all he is healing people in that context
so you can't look at it say well Jesus
obviously isn't the Son of God cuz it
was healing one guy not to I mean that's
the next one message you ready for this
yeah in the Old Testament it says an eye
for an eye but in the New Testament it
teaches differently in the sermon of the
mount or in the Sermon on the Mount
Jesus says you have heard it said an eye
for an eye and a tooth for a tooth but I
say turn-the-other-cheek contradiction
that's a more tough one man yeah that's
a more tough one which was it what is
the purpose of what Jesus is doing on
the Sermon on the Mount that's the
question because that helps clarify
what's going on here is Jesus saying
well you've heard it said this way so
now throw that out know Jesus is taking
the Old Testament and he's saying let's
put everything in its proper context
let's put everything in its proper
meaning let me expand to you the details
of what all this means because you've
gone through years of this teaching and
it's become kind of humdrum if you will
it's been taught this way and so you've
only understood it one way this whole
time
now let me like really open it up for
you so it's not a contradiction
it's Jesus saying no after all you know
the Bible says that God is not the
author of confusion right so Jesus
wouldn't come from God to contradict
what God had said
the Holy Spirit would not have inspired
one writer to say this and then you know
inspired Jesus to Satan I mean
absolutely not I mean that's it's
completely ludicrous right so put it
let's put it in a modern setting you
know you have every right to get a
divorce if your spouse cheats on you
right
so kind of what I see Jesus saying in
this setting is he's they seem like you
have the right to divorce your wife but
I'm gonna tell you let's ask for
forgiveness you have that right but
let's ask for forgiveness and let's look
past what your right is and let's be
higher than that
you know what I mean there's any sense
yeah just out of curiosity not throwing
it away he's literally saying you know
that that's right you know if someone
knocks your tooth out I mean you should
be able to knock their tooth out right
but the better option here would be
don't get into a fight be the bigger
person and don't don't engage in that
love that person so he's widening the
tunnel view that's right guys okay last
one number three events okay in Genesis
1 verse 27 it says that man and woman
were made together but in Genesis
chapter 3 verse 21 and 22 it says they
were made separate and woman was brought
to men well which one is it
contradiction so if you make if you make
some if you make some spaghetti and some
bread on the same day you know I mean
it's like you made a meal and you made
these things together that to me is like
not specifying
you know like like there was this whole
separate event or they were supposed to
be made at the exact same simultaneous
time but you also have to understand a
little bit about the Jewish writing they
told you the punchline first then they
went back and showed you detail so we're
we in the English language we would
typically write in big picture and then
drill down as you get closer to the to
the end of the chapter so to me it's
like there was a statement that was made
God made both of these and then later on
he's telling how he made no it's
actually reversed so what's what's the
problem again that they're saying is I
don't see a problem but really it's just
the full picture in Chapter 1 and
detail in Chapter two like I'd love to
see an atheist like allow us to have an
argument like that with them you know
they'd be like are you kidding me right
yeah yes so these things are quite small
fall apart but just as the Bible can can
defend itself can stand on its own hold
its own weight for those small things it
could do the same for the big ones as
well I think those things get amplified
when you start having doubts you know
that's that's the problem is when you're
looking for a reason to doubt then
you're gonna find something latch onto
it and make a bigger deal out of it so
so I would almost suggest that if you
know somebody that's listening to this
led it is having doubts and maybe agrees
with some of those doubts if you
actually take a step back don't drill in
so in fine detail and nitpick okay he
said this word and he did this look at
the big picture of Christianity what's
the overarching goal of Christianity how
is my life bettered if I adhere to these
these goals and and and sort of just you
know it's okay to take a step back and
sort of analyze it from up from a big
picture I think if you're like finally
looking for a sentence in this 2,000
page book that that is gonna you know
give you the answer that you're out
you're setting yourself up for that so
just take a step back and take a
breather and and think about
Christianity as a whole I like what Ken
Ham says he'd said this in response to
Marty actually when Bible passages are
properly understood there are no
contradictions this situation talking
about Marty situation about this person
is a reminder the church and parents
need to teach apologetics to counter
today's attacks on God's Word so this is
this really struck home because I
remember growing up in the church we
were really active in the community as a
youth group we would go and paint the
the park and you know feed the homeless
and do all these things but we never had
Bible study like in the church mmm like
we never came together as young people
and just opened the Bible and studied it
and it made me wonder you know do the
people in the church really know what
the youth believe mm-hm and how quickly
can someone end up like Marty Simpson
and if you're not kind of giving them
the tools to be able to handle and and
and understand when people have
questions you know those questions can
sit in the mind and plant a seed and
then you know choke out the truth and so
I think that's a very wise advice to
teach apologetics and learn how to
handle it when somebody has a doubt and
they come at you with a doubt you know
yeah how do you play it I used to go to
the youth pastor after the sermon and
ask him why is this why is that and he
would say some things we just won't know
so we get to heaven I mean what kind of
cop out is that I mean it was when I got
later in life and I saw people like Kent
Hovind defend the creationism and Walter
vice and these people like it made
perfect clear scientifically accurate
evidence like debunking theories like
Darwinian evolution with science like
people need to see that kind of stuff or
else they're just gonna think Christians
believe a bunch of fairy tales how can
God be loved yes and four billion people
to a place all because they don't
believe no one talks about it now that
raised a lot of questions and
first off where'd he get the number four
billion and I can assume he's talking
about how the place hot topic right
there I know where he got the number
four billion
he watched the Marvel endgame yeah yeah
explain half of the world gets destroyed
by Thanos I think where it comes in is
let's see Catholicism represents about
how many people about a billion I don't
know and Christianity collectively
beyond that it's probably somewhere
approaching that number so that's about
your two billion I think and then the
rest of the world is this
you know Hindu Buddhist I'm guessing
that's probably close to where the
homers coming that's all we can do yes
he doesn't specify it's big but I also
think that once again you have to
understand how God is making that
judgment we call him the righteous judge
because he's able to judge based on
somebody's life so if you basically get
to the point where you are are not
wanting to go to heaven God's not gonna
force you to go to heaven that's what I
love the same only those that want to go
to heaven will be in heaven I mean if
you are going to be miserable God in His
mercy would not put you there in a place
that you would be miserable and so you
know I think that at the end of the
judgment that's why every tongue will
profess every knee will bow everyone
even down to Satan and his angels say
God you were right
we were wrong you've judged righteously
and we don't deserve to be in ever end
up in your everlasting kingdom so you
have to understand the concept of the
context of how God is saying this to
make that decision if you just look at
it on its surface just like you would
fan os-- just destroying half of
humanity just because there's no reason
that looks unmerciful but it actually is
completely merciful when you look at the
context of how God is doing that God is
God is pursuing humanity you know
when he says God is love yet they're
sending them place because they don't
believe God is not sending anybody
anywhere because they don't believe God
is making a judgment call based on your
response to him and I fear response is
rejection I don't want you then God says
you can have what you want yeah just
like that I'm not the person putting it
back on the person they're the ones
making my business and I think that's
why everybody is if you want to be a
Satanist and follow Satan God let's you
knew that to me that's awesome I want to
serve that kind of God if you're gonna
let me do that and he let Satan
literally fight against him and drag a
bunch of the other angels God did not
force those other angels to go you know
on Satan's side they could no longer
abide together in heaven when they
didn't abide by heavens rules and God
just said hey you're causing discord you
need to go and so that that's what I see
yeah though the free will that he allows
is the very definition of love the fact
that he didn't destroy Satan on the spot
displays that love if he would have
destroyed Satan right then imagine the
thoughts that would have been going
through all the watching angels Minds
like wow okay don't ever go outside the
box because you will be destroyed and
then their their motivation for worship
would be fear-based
so we're worshiping because if we don't
you'll just destroy us that's not really
the way it is God is giving you a gift I
want you to have this life he's
long-suffering not willing that any
should perish but look what look at the
world look at a time lapse of the world
and see where we're at now and how many
people are just openly rejecting him and
they're gonna be the ones to say oh well
he's just gonna send me someplace
because I don't believe like you hate
him and you hate his people it's kind of
an interesting argument if you were to
play it out in your head
say the words okay you know here's like
this person they don't believe it I
don't believe in you God if God were to
answer okay
I'm angry you won't let me go to heaven
you God's response what heaven you don't
believe in me how can there be a heaven
for you to be upset that you don't get
to go to you yeah right I mean yeah I
mean that's cut to the ridiculousness to
the point of the you know conversation
if it was before the played out so let's
see Christian's Christian's can be the
most judgmental people on the planet
this is this is true they can't be they
can also be some of the most beautiful
and loving people this is also true and
this is true of secular people as well
yeah very judgmental and they can be
there's a teaming condition this is but
it's not for me I am NOT in anymore
I want genuine truth not just the I
believe it kind of truth should we keep
going science keeps piercing the truth
of every religion lots of things help
people change their lives not just one
version of God
got so much more to say but for me I
keeping it real I guess a met something
else
unfollow if you want I've never been
about living my life for others all I
know is what's true to me right now and
Christianity just seems to be to me
like another religion at this point I
could go on but I won't love it let's
pause right there
okay I'm Scott I remember you saying
something about that when he said
I've never been about living my life for
others yes yeah yeah when we started
kind of chatting about this before we
came on here that's a very interesting
concept because the entire way of
Christianity is others focused you know
and I mean so the fact that you're kind
of even mentioning I've not been about
living about other people I'm literally
doing this for myself I understand he
might be talking about the concept of
like it's not influencing making his
decision so I don't want to like totally
put it on him that he's not being others
focused but it's kind of an interesting
interesting statement I like science
keeps piercing science keeps piercing
the truth of every religion
I wonder what religions and I wonder
what science but what I've seen when I
started looking at science keeps proving
the Bible over and over the skeptics
doubted that Babylon existed and they
excavated excavated the walls of Babylon
like boom there with the name
Nebuchadnezzar on the bricks and over we
just scroll which proved the Book of
Daniel you know yeah we're like oh this
is just some book that's made up and yet
we find and discover a piece of history
that proves it so yeah I would question
what science is he looking at what's
interesting to me yes he goes from this
I want genuine truth not he just I just
believe it kind of truth and then from
there he starts a listing a whole bunch
of things but you know the implication
is that he's not getting genuine truth
in Christianity and you know these are
these are like the reasons why after
this you know lots of things help people
change their lives not just one version
of God you know science etc etc I guess
my question might be is if you want
genuine truth in Christianity and you're
not finding it what are you reading what
are you watching what are you studying
who are you hanging out with you know
what we put into our mind greatly
affects what we think if you spend all
day not to say that he is but I'm just
using us an example if you spend all day
reading books on evolution humanism you
know atheism you're likely gonna be
greatly influenced to be of the same
mindset because that's what you're
taking in so I see a lot of I see a lot
of you know frustration here it's it's
almost like okay I'm gonna look at
what's going on around me and
Christianity yeah I've looked at the
Bible don't see any of that in here so
ok see you guys check it out and you
know it's like we're all on this walk
and journey to be like Jesus if we're a
genuine Christian and to give up and say
well nobody here is like Jesus
you all are too much of a screw-up you
know guess I'm gonna go look for
something else well I mean if you look
at Revelation chapter 3 which is you
know talking about the different
churches you can understand that some
people understand this differently but
understand it and talking about periods
of history you look at the last church
it says that this is like the most
screwed up Church basically out of all
of them right
they're rich they're increased with
Goods they don't mean anything right yet
they're naked yeah yeah and they're
blind you might say this is a church of
the hypocrites right and but God says
it's it's still my church and yes it's
gonna be messed up don't don't go into
it expecting that it's gonna be perfect
people come in to Christianity
oftentimes thinking these people should
all be perfect I mean they're so so good
that like why aren't they in heaven
right now right we're all still human
really his observation is proving but
you're obviously true right but you know
what's awesome what does Jesus end that
with by of me yeah he totally has a
rarity yeah there's a remedy for our
sickness and so you know that remedy is
only found in Jesus so we're all messed
up and he's recognizing that were messed
up really
the antidote to our messed up miss is
Jesus yeah nothing to check it out
no yeah not getting that injecting
yourself from the game or whatever is
right go back to Jesus show us how to be
a real yourself in Christ immerse
yourself in His Word discover him in his
word I mean that's how you're gonna do
it right and I think God is a God that
is like tests me go ahead you know if
you've got questions and doubts bring
them to me bring them to my to my foot
of my cross and I will show you who I am
if you ask God that show me who you are
he's not going to ignore you
mm-hmm though and you hold your hand up
and you go you know what I'm gonna try
it without him though yeah I mean it's
it's like if I come into Christianity I
say okay well this whole thing is not
true not authentic because look at all
these people yeah well so what about all
those people what has it done for you in
your life like is it changing you are
you having an experience with Christ are
you walking with him because if you're
walking with him good you know
now you can influence other people but
if you just look around and kind of
throw your hands up and say well this
didn't work you know yeah and uh almost
like a cop-out
yeah this guy probably wouldn't like it
if somebody judged him by what his
bandmates were doing
yet he's judging God by what his
followers are doing mate that's good
point yeah well after emphasising that
he's truly seeking answers
Samson admitted that he's struggling
with many parts of the belief system
that seems so in coherence with common
human morality okay if most of humankind
had a choice would we not rid the world
of the scourge of cancer or sickness and
disease why doesn't God do such a thing
of course there is an answer to this
question but the majority of a typical
Christians life is not spent considering
these things questions such as these
remain in the too hard basket all right
well let's consider it let's try to
answer that question why doesn't God do
something about sickness and disease
suffering so I would almost kind of even
back out a little bit more what's the
purpose of sickness and disease sin
right
I mean sin entered into the world things
start dying everybody's bodies are
degenerating right so why doesn't God
just solve the sin problem right now
because he has to allow the freedom
that's that's the that's what we're
dealing with we're dealing with a God
that is literally giving the other side
the opposition to his government a
chance to have a voice and say listen if
you think that running the show you're
way outside of God's Ten Commandments is
going to be good for Humanity then I
will lay you before kings and they can
see that your ways and I will let you
exhaust every question and so at the end
of the world when everybody's dying I
think it's just interesting that
everybody wants to point their finger at
God and be like why aren't you solving
this right now because God is allowing
Satan to have his voice though and allow
him to play this out and that would not
be fair if all of a sudden if you serve
God your life's just gonna be peachy and
you're never gonna have any problems and
you're gonna be rich and you're gonna be
this right are you kidding me every
human being would sign up for God in a
heartbeat so that's not that's not fair
No you know also you got a you got to
kind of ask where is this cancer
sickness and disease coming from not to
go completely down a conspiracy theory
train but when you look at the chemicals
in our food water air it's like I hate
to read us every day why don't have
cancer you know like we don't do the
best for our own health how we're gonna
blame God that well I ate junk food all
the time I have cancer so you bring up
an interesting point which I strongly
believe in you find it in Galatians 6 I
think it's verse 5 and paraphrasing it
says you know whatever man sews he reaps
it'll say it differently in different
versions but basically you know the end
point you reap what you sow that's a
biblical principle and so we see that
played out in humanity from the very
beginning you know the identic pair were
worn look if you do this there's going
to be consequences that follow well we
did it and there are consequences that
have followed and some people think well
it's not fair that everybody should have
to suffer for that choice but if you
think about it you are born and you get
into life and you have your own choices
to make and do you always make the right
choices in every circumstance in every
situation you know are we all that
different from them you know here they
they they were they were perfect you
know perfect minds perfect bodies
perfect reasoning capable
they were also deceived
to see and you know when deception is a
is a powerful thing now they have to
make a choice always can I just kind of
put it like this when II was in the
garden and and she's listening to what
the serpent is is telling her she'd
never been lied to in fact think about
it what's a lie what's a lie
you know you've never heard a lot now
you're presented with two completely
different pieces of information you know
what God said and then this one says
something over here and you have to make
a choice and discern between those two
who you trust
you know she trusted the wrong one she
didn't trust the one that loved her and
made her and had taken care of her so
far she trusted somebody that was
bringing her some other information
then there's also you know why is there
starvation all this stuff there are
people on the there are people on earth
that have enough money to fix the hunger
problem they don't love of money is the
root of all evil
there are wicked people in high places
with all the money that could fix all
this but who are the people that are
actually trying to make a difference
look at the people who are going to
these starving places and bring you food
Christians all the time you know where
hospitals come from yeah I get sick of
the ESA when there's a natural disaster
this is how Christians help out they
pray no look at the list of all the
priests sonogram all the hospitals all
the orphanages all this stuff our
Christian organizations even I saw a
meme where it showed it was a comic of
Christians protesting about pro-life and
there's like these orphans reaching out
and she's like now dude
that made me so angry because I'm like
how many people actually adopt how many
they're Christians how many people are
run orphanages they're Christians most
of the time the majority they are the
ones that care enough they're the ones
that are acting like Christ you bring up
a really good point because there's a
lot of very wealthy people in our
country and even outside of our country
I mean Jeff Bezos you know you talk
about Facebook you talk about any of
these major corporations that literally
single-handedly those individuals could
almost solve world hunger and they don't
how come people aren't mentioning that
how come they're not like literally
going hey look dude you know you've got
way more than you can even spend if you
spent ten thousand dollars every single
day till the day you died you still
would have money in the bank like that
that is so much money what do you need
that for why aren't we commenting on
that it's like everyone wants to always
point the finger at God and say but you
know you're not solving this problem and
you know like you you have you're a
parent if you if you decide to all of a
sudden like I'm gonna do drugs and my
kids gonna suffer from that right you
know is it God's job to all of us ID and
just take away those choices that you as
a parent made for them and
and you know I mean what does that do
for you and you don't see the effects of
that I mean there's just a lot of
dynamics here with God that he has to
allow these he doesn't want to but he
has to allow them because of himself
being on trial and yet God is the one
who's given most you know he is the
greatest Giver he is the one that we
learned to give from and so we'll we'll
throw these things out here like what
God wanted do this it's like well look
at what God has done the God's goal is
not to necessarily make our lives
perfect here you know like perfect as in
material as in we have you know no more
hunger no it you know he said repent for
the kingdom of heaven is at hand
right any-any said in another place my
kingdom is not of this world
right he is trying to prepare us for the
world to come that that is the the
bigger grander picture it's it's like
you know we're stuck here and we
complain about here and it's like what
what what do is it what do we have here
that we want to hold on to so much
that's that's worth it you know I guess
saving outside of people what's what's
so great you know because we have the
sickness we have the disease we have all
that you know the Bible describes as
Christians as pilgrims we are passing
through this land to a better land you
know we're on our way to a heavenly
Canaan this place is a temporary holding
place right we're here for now we make
the best of it as as we're able and the
best for others we make the choice for
God and Goddess said you know and you
make the choice for me and you what's in
store for you is eternal life in a place
that is beyond what you can imagine
so no more pain no more sorrow he
actually promises tribulation and
persecution - I mean it there's no
promise of this is gonna be easy and he
says what profits a man if he gains the
whole world lose his own soul I mean
there's a lot of stuff like that
that tells us live for the kingdom not
for this now yeah so Marty Samson's next
post showed me that he was still
grabbing on both sides and it really
brought to my attention how important it
is for us to assess why people walk out
the church door because it could be a
myriad of reasons and that there is a
difference between leaving the church
versus leaving God if you go up to
someone and ask them why they left the
church it could be you know maybe there
was a triggering situation maybe not
even in the church but maybe where the
church is located and it just can't show
up there anymore and then they go find
another fellowship you know helping them
through that process I think we'll keep
more people within community instead of
assuming that they've left God starting
to live a very authentic life now
finally not that I wasn't authentic
before but now I am being more holy
authentic to the true me so here's
what's up I still love Jesus but I am
NOT a part of Hillsong anymore I still
love God but I do not want to set foot
in a church again hear what I am saying
it's not that I never will but right now
I don't want to nothing wrong with
someone else going but I don't want to
myself do series coming from he's kind
of like taking a step back and trying to
assess himself like his belief his
personal relationship with Christ
outside of maybe everyone else and
whatever may have been going on in
Hillsong or whatever the case he's
trying to be authentic he still loves
Jesus he's probably still praying well
at this point in time and still seeking
and it would be great if somebody was
there to
and help him to keep reassuring that hey
the answers are in the Bible I think
it's just it's just so important for us
to know why people are walking out the
door and not assume all the time because
they may still be on fire for the Lord
there's just maybe something within the
the fellowship that's the issue I'm
saying that I'm the happiest I've ever
been in my life and I'm grateful to be
alive grateful to God and to you all for
following me I love you
the future is bright I will say this I
love everyone that is a part of Hillsong
and have zero beef with anyone there
zero it's just not for me and I respect
myself enough to tell you all that god
bless you all
you know I mean you really have to to
hand it to him he's being honest with
the situation he's walking out and
saying listen I'm not giving up on God
at this point I'm giving up on this this
this idea of a picture of Christianity
that I've surrounded myself with and
maybe he just needs to like push the
reset button you know get back to God
the one thing that I would leave someone
that is questioning this and I think
it's it's it's for whatever reason like
you said there's a myriad of reasons why
someone would go through this and it's
hard to understand and be in somebody's
shoes when they do go through this but
if you're really honest and you come to
God and with it with an open heart you
say God I want to seek truth like he's
clearly seeking truth he said he wants
to see truth if you come to God like
that you open your heart to him and say
listen if if this is the truth show it
to me and I will respond to it
I believe God will not ignore you he
would put people in your life he'll put
circumstances in your life he'll heal
like the Bible says he will direct your
path to go right or to go left if that's
the heart that he's given to him and the
best place to be is that openness to God
I think the hardest place is I'm gonna
close off my my experience with God and
I'm gonna walk away and I'm gonna try
this on my own I think you're stepping
on a dangerous ground at that point
okay well Simpson told The Christian
Post that he had begun to study both
sides over the issue of of this debates
regarding Christianity by studying
apologists such as William Craig gen
Linux Ravi Zacharias Michael Mike ona
and up Frank
Tareq do any of these names sound
familiar
Robbie yeah yeah sure
he's probably in this situation where
he's read these verses he's read the
Bible I seen these things over and over
and it's you know it's like you said
he's he's numb so going back to that
without putting it in a different
context or mindset is is probably not
gonna be helpful to him and that's
probably why he's turned into people
like this because it's like okay I keep
seeing this and thinking the same way
over and over again like I'm hitting a
brick wall I need help
you know to expound upon that like what
does this all mean how do I understand
this and so it's like listening to a
sermon you read something in the Bible
you you get to a certain point and maybe
you want to understand it more you
listen to a sermon on it you get a
slightly different perspective and it
can help you see things that in the
Bible that maybe you didn't see and so
then you can continue to further your
study and expound upon that so I don't
know that I would entirely fault him for
that it you know I think he's looking
for perspective
and you know I've done that myself you
know you you understand so far you want
to understand more sometimes you just
you can hit a brick wall and you're
reading the Bible and certain you should
you should pray through that but it can
be helpful you know to dialogue with
people who are like-minded to get a bit
more perspective you know kind of
bouncing things off of people you know
will do that in in the office from time
to time they're you know you're right
I would agree with that I think it's
helpful well what do you guys think
about studying both sides of the debate
as a Christian to actually submerge
yourself in the opposite side atheistic
views evolution and these things do you
think that Christians should study those
things I would wonder if you're wavering
on your faith if trying to run to the
argument that is trying to discount
Christianity is really a smart choice
it's almost like if you're wavering like
let me go listen to the reasons why you
should it be a Christian because I I
don't quite believe this yet so I'm
gonna set this aside I'm gonna go kind
of surround myself with people who are
very strongly against it I think that's
that's once again dangerous ground if
you're wavering I would almost want to
run to people I respect in the Christian
faith because if you look at it in the
whole context if I totally lose my
religion what do I actually lose if if I
get to the end of my life and that's it
there's no more there's really no heaven
or hell or whatever like this there's
there's just nothing beyond it well it
really doesn't matter if I believe over
here right but if you're kind of in the
Christian camp and you go wow I may be
losing out on an eternity if I go to
that side of the fence you know I'm
gonna forfeit my my opportunity for for
an eternity I just would not run to the
argument I would run to someone else
that bet either has their feet on solid
ground or you know and really grapple
with it like please I'm having a
struggle in this area like you know give
me help with what what you understand
about this vital says a house divided
against itself cannot stand you know so
I see that in this situation if he's
truly looking at both sides you know not
just listening to people like Ravi
Zacharias and other apologists but he's
really going to okay what is what is
anti-christian literature say about
Christianity
I would agree it's very dangerous and I
think it's gonna shipwreck him and he
will not stand you know it will just
continue to decline all right well I
just want to wrap this up and also give
a word of encouragement I was speaking
to a cousin of mine and the question
came up
are there any Bible characters that may
have gone through this same experience
of losing their faith and we thought
about it for a while
does any character come up in your mind
and I wonder about solving the ending of
his story yeah you know I think there's
there's definitely examples of some very
questionable prominent people that sort
of like I don't know if they written
Jack did God they certificate does
anyone come to mind um Balaam you know
okay it's like you know here go curse
these people well the money sounds
pretty good you know it's like he either
wasn't understanding the full scope of
God which is hilarious that God let him
go you know I mean once again it's like
gods like okay fine if you want to go
then he goes in he actually you know
blesses the people which you know he was
a willing instrument of God but he was
warring with his human humans health
inside that Jonah Jonah showing up and
true you know like fighting against that
but I don't know if I necessarily
remember any
I mean Saul rejected God that name came
up sure and you know going and seeing
the Witch of Endor rather than going to
God I mean he clearly knew I mean this
is not someone who was unaware of the
fact that God told his people to have
nothing to do with witchcraft
for someone struggling wrestling with
their faith I mean
first off we'd like to tell you that
you're not alone and this has been going
on throughout history the two names that
came up in the conversation with my
cousin and I were Peter and Judas and
there are similarities and also vast
differences between the two you look at
the similarities both were disciples of
Jesus they saw him like witnessed him do
miracles they called him his friend but
they weren't converted both of them were
not converted but the difference is one
came back to Christ and had a conversion
experience and the other committed
suicide both said that they had a
relationship with Christ I wondered what
was lacking yeah you know I always
wonder like if Judas would have
literally humbled his heart and and said
God you know I totally see my mistake
would you take me back of course God to
take him back right and can you imagine
being the only guy in heaven that's like
I killed God you know like what a crazy
like you know there's the guy that like
really you know killed our maker but the
fact that that both him and Peter denied
Jesus really yet one came back and the
other one thought that he had gone too
far I think that the one that had gone
too far if I can kind of just on a
superficial level judge what he was
doing he stepped outside of the bounds
of God and then really just lost all
hope and when he lost all hope there
seemed like there was no way forward
from this point and I think that's the
danger of walking away from God it is a
hopeless world out there if you don't
have this this you know hope in God to
helping us through these times and so
you know to let go of God and say I'm
gonna just go and flow it out into the
ocean for a little while I mean yeah is
it isn't it Paul who says you know if
Christ is not risen your hope is in vain
it's like you have
if Jesus did not rise from the dead you
know which is one of the proofs that he
is who he said that he was you know and
that he goes on to have an inmediate on
our behalf but if you had nothing after
that you know it's like what else what
else is there he says there's nothing
your hope is in vain forget it hands
over the dough you hit the nail on the
head
the question was what was lacking both
had a relationship with Christ but what
was lacking what did one find that the
other one didn't and there's really two
main things humility and also love these
two things there's a formula in second
chronicles chapter 7 verse 14 is that
familiar if my people who are called by
my name who also that be Christians you
know people who follow Christ if my
people who are called by my name will
humble themselves yeah that's the first
one seek my face sorry
humble themselves pray seek my face and
turn from their wicked ways then I will
restore them the first step the most
powerful step is humility Peter went to
Christ and said I'm sorry Judas didn't
do that it was there was elements of
pride in his heart Judas went to the
religious leaders and they weren't able
to offer him the forgiveness and the
restoration that Jesus can offer so that
was one area humility the next one is
love Peter is then reinstated as part of
the Christ group and his as part of the
eleven now eleven disciples where Jesus
asked one question three times remember
what that question was do you love me
yes do you love me Peter do you love me
and Peter's like of course I love you I
could even ask that question and I was
doing some research into that and just
blew my mind so in the English language
we have the word love and it's one word
it means a whole heap of different
things depending on the situation but we
have one word love in the Greek there's
four words for love
I found that very interesting that kind
of sucks because we just read the Bible
and we say love love love but in the
Greek it's two different words Jesus
saying Peter do you love me and the word
that Jesus is using is agape or agave oh
don't quote me on that pronunciation you
can look it up but um Jesus is asking
that the definition of agape is to love
unconditionally and sacrificially as
Jesus himself loves sinful men and we
said that kind of love in John 3:16 so
Jesus is like do you love me
unconditionally and Peter's like of
course I love you but the love Peter is
using the word is filio ph IL e o which
is motivated by superficial appearance
emotional attraction and sentimental
relationship like I love this apple
exactly so Jesus is like do you love me
unconditionally and Peter is like me of
course I love you as a friend and this
is exchanges going back and forth with
Jesus trying to get him to understand
that you have a relationship with me you
say you love me but it's the wrong kind
of love it's not the lasting
unconditional love that was what was
lacking in their relationship that is
what unfortunately Judas did not find
that was the missing link and the
answers came at the feet of Jesus and
those are that's where the truth lies
that's where that the answer is that's
where you can find what what elements in
my relationship with Jesus is missing
how can I be restored back to my strong
Christian faith so I encourage anyone
who is listening who may be struggling
with their faith to humble yourself go
read second Corinthians chapter chapter
seven and also um John chapter three I
believe it's John thought today and and
that was also my prayer for Marty
Sampson as he is on his quest for truth
FETs
find it in Jesus we thank you so much
for watching this episode of LED live if
you have any questions or any topics
you'd like us to cover leave them down
in the comment section below
we're hoping that these kind of topics
discussions these episodes spark a
discussion in your church or an or in
your home
so please share this video to as many
people as possible and we will see you
next week on LED live bye bye
[Music]